i wouldn't mind doing a residency in
vegas really
how does this [ __ ] end though oh not
good and we're talking about
ralphie's ends
damn little ralphie that's what they
would call it oh my god what if the last
special you did
was just like uh ralphie may that was
the name of it
oh man and you look just like ralph like
you were that crazy
dude i i i mean i feel guilty now
i know that i had nothing to do with
this but me and him were on a cruise
ship
right before he passed like a few months
before he passed does he sleep in the
middle of a [ __ ] he has to sleep in the
middle of a cruise ship
at 600 pounds or 500 pounds you couldn't
sleep on the side of the cruise ship
could you
he was sleeping a lot that trip he
wasn't getting up and doing much
and uh and i went we went to his room
once a day and we'd go in there and
smoke a joint in his room
and uh and what he's just laying in bed
the whole time he was laying in bed a
lot he'd get up and move around
i mean i mean i'm i'm not i'm definitely
not speaking ill of the dead but anyone
was on that ship would agree
he'd move around like probably two out
of the seven days we were there
he'd get up and do stuff and he not
often
not often was he moving around and when
you say like like
because i've never been around anybody
that has had that much of a
you know an impairment that wasn't like
you know i had a friend that didn't have
any legs and he didn't do that much
and then um i had another lady that i
think was just lazy when i was growing
up you know and she also was taking care
of a kid a black child
yeah and both her and her husband were
white and they were pretending like it
was their child to everybody
even though the lady that swept at his
school bus was black
miss tilly and it was obviously her
child and we'd go over there and it was
the weirdest thing
like this our son boogie and it would be
like something
dude they had him dressed up like a
little cowboy and [ __ ] like to make him
just seem even wider
dude i no joke i remember this little
boogie he'd have on these red boots and
he would do this little [ __ ] dance by
the door when you went in
and it was like what like even i know
that you can't get a black kid out of
two white people no matter how hard you
try
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one